so let me welcome everybody to session
three of the classic metal class and and
class we're using in kind of a loose
sense this isn't you know for credit or
anything like that we when Scott and I
were kicking around this idea we thought
about chant but that was a little bit
too informal and there were a few other
ideas but there is kind of a structure
to this so Scott and I are gonna be
discussing some stuff we can we can take
some Q&A pauses in the middle of it and
address stuff but usually what we do is
we present for a while and then we we do
a lot of answering questions Scott is a
professor of guitar it's kind of a cool
thing to be a professor of at the School
of Music he's a musician who's done a
lot of gig work a lot of studio work has
three albums to his name and it like me
is a lifelong metalhead all of you know
me i'm i build myself as the heavy metal
philosopher I was surprised nobody had
already taken up that slot look I have a
blog by that name and what we do in this
is we we talk about some stuff having to
do with music history and our shared
love of these different bands but we
also bring in some some philosophical
ideas and questions and today what we're
going to be talking about is identity
for bands and what what constitutes a
bands identity over time so we're
getting into some metaphysical questions
and if this is prompted in part by
people bringing these things up in the
the previous classes and in discussions
that we've been having for a long time
sometimes prompted by what people are
you know actually doing in the real
world like when rat had two different
rival rats until that was legally
decided as it often happens in these
cases so Before we jump in I wanted to
discuss very quickly one of the
questions that I hold all of you on as
sort of a baseline so I asked all
of you if a band has no original members
should we consider it to still be that
band and 50% of you said in all or most
cases no it is no longer that band 50%
of you were willing to say yeah in some
cases it's still that band in other
cases no and nobody said sure so long as
there's continuity it's still that band
and I think this is really interesting
because if well there there we go from
Chris he's already anticipating where
I'm going with this if we look at works
teams right sports teams you know here
in Wisconsin we have the Pat and we have
the Packers and Aaron Rodgers is an
integral member of the team but he's
gonna retire someday and you know that's
that's gonna be a different team and you
know we shuffle people in and shuffle
people out
Bruce points out that Symphony
Orchestra's do remain the same over time
so there's yeah the genre music makes a
difference and I was doing a little bit
of digging around online to get a little
bit you know bit of background on this
and I think that it may not be the case
you know metal might be kind of an
innate that one side of this I think in
some other genres of music people are
more willing to say that a band can be
the same band
even though as no original members
whereas we're going to talk about a
little bit later perhaps no essential
members you know if you think about boy
bands like menudo for example the whole
business model of menudo is you shuffle
guys in you shuffle guys up now that
couldn't work with our made it or
somebody else who we are talking about
briefly before this with Motorhead and
we'll get into reasons why so
metaphysical issues right I'm not going
to go into like a long dissertation
about this but I'll point out a few
things that fall within the scope of
what we call metaphysics in philosophy
one is that what we're talking about
here is is sameness things remaining the
same over time
and I want to say that this is an
ambiguous term it doesn't mean the same
thing you know that we could say
sameness is not the same in every case
by the way if you want to look for an
early discussion of this that's playing
around with those ideas plato's sophist
discusses sameness and you know whether
sameness is the same and all of that the
the biggest thing that we're looking at
here is not just sameness though but
identity what is it that you know in a
band keeps it being the same band and
Bruce was you know we were joking around
a little bit before that he showed me
his van Halen t-shirt went for quite a
few people when David Lee Roth left and
Sammy Hagar joined they were like I
don't know if this is Van Halen anymore
even though were the two van Halen
brothers of course we're still in it and
so you know these are some really
interesting metaphysical issues and more
broadly speaking we can say okay well
what is it that actually remains the
same through all of these changes that
are happening that is a classic question
in philosophy that goes all the way back
in the West to pre-socratic philosophers
and then is approached in Plato and
Aristotle of the Hellenistic
philosophers all the way down to the
present so we're gonna you know I'm not
going to be bringing up a lot of
different philosophers but we're gonna
apply some of these ideas in terms of
these these bands the other thing that
we might want to think about is
continuity you know this is really
important when it comes to the
relationship between parts and wholes
and we can look at a band as being some
kind of holy unity that musicians are
parts of you know like when we think
about putting together super bands which
almost never work you know the parts
aren't really that compatible with each
other but in the case of a lot of these
other long-standing bands we do have
some sort of unified whole at least
until it starts shedding loft parts and
bringing in new parts
so when we're thinking about the the
unity comprised by a band it's tempting
just to look at the members of the band
but I think we might also think in terms
of a couple other factors as well and I
don't have some sort of unified theory
of this I mean here's where I'm going to
turn it over to Scott in just a second
get his take on this as well I think the
members are important and we can also
talk about the staff or support of the
band you know the managers the people
who are doing that all the behind the
scene good mixer is absolutely essential
right and then we can also talk about
the etho or the image of the band
something that's more conceptual but
also effective and the sound is
important and that I definitely want to
hear what Scott has to say about that
from sort of music College of Music
illogical perspective but I also think
that we can talk about the unity of a
band residing partly in its catalog the
the recorded things and then it's set
lists at concerts so Scott is there
anything I've left out to begin with and
then what else you know when it comes to
the sound how do we actually
conceptualize that well I want to
actually start and go back because the
the point about the orchestra is not a
genre thing so an orchestra is basically
they're playing mostly classic works
right we're not having creative
contributions from the violin section
you're not having and you know the eras
are based on the conductor but then take
like a metal band like the
trans-siberian Orchestra oh yeah they
can you can trade out players every
season and it's still treant because
it's these aren't individual bands these
are more like what would you call not a
business but you know well you know
there's there's a conversation going on
in the chat that's kind of germane to
that Bruce points out that gene Simmons
he says he doesn't want to be in a rock
and roll band he wants to be in a rock
and roll brand
so anyways I just thought he'd point out
that that's not so much a genre thing
but if you have an organization yeah so
trans-siberian orchestra clearly a metal
thing that happens around Christmas you
can have Joel home screw in one time
Chris caffee and another you can have
Jeff Scott Soto sing and there's also an
s west coast and an East Coast version
of the band oh I didn't know that
so there's players on the west coast
it's a franchise that well that's what
it is okay I guess that's what I'm try
saying now so that but that's a great
point because trans-siberian Orchestra
you could buy those records but nobody's
concerned with who's in it as long as
it's a metal music there usually
well-known metal musicians so they're
interchangeable as far as sound do you
mean as the sound changes with new
members like Sammy Hagar joins in the
sound of Van Halen took a different
direction you know that that's a great
example because there was such a radical
change in sound if we and I think it's
very helpful to think about examples
when we're going through these sorts of
things
so let's contrast that to say the
Scorpions going from Livan wrath to
Matthias jabs less of I mean there's a
change that's discernible but it's less
of a radical change
I suppose in part because Hagar is not
only contributing different vocals in a
way quite different from David Lee
Roth's right but also playing some
guitar stuff on it too and and part of
the writing process now right right
which is a big thing and you know we
shouldn't we shouldn't forget about
technology so the 80s was probably most
unique periods in music pop music
history where all of a sudden nobody was
playing traditional instruments if
they're playing fender Stratocasters
they were super strats with all this new
stuff
nobody wanted to was interested in using
the technology from before keyboards
became polyphonic meaning you could play
more than one note
yeah and these sounds were introduced in
all music not just metal but you know we
started to hear it's you know in turbo
you know just
yeah I was just about to say Judas
Priest had reached sort of its apex in
heaviness with defenders of the faith
yeah the guitars are very distorted and
it's you know the bass is very very
heavy very hard and then suddenly they
introduce the the guitar synths and
people some people are always amazing
and other people are like they have
betrayed us same thing with our Raiden
and somewhere in time as well you know
you know and that's an interesting thing
just you know kind of the talks we've
had on how the emotions work how fans
get angry yeah you know in it they take
it personally yeah but I remember
somewhere in time I mean all of a sudden
the marshals went away and they were
using what they call Rock meds and oh
just to tell the people that don't know
what a Rahman is Tom Schultz from the
band Boston invented an amplifier and if
you hear those Boston records that
really kind of funky weird futuristic
sounding guitars he always had well
those were Rockman's and Iron Maiden
dropped the marshals and took the rock
ones that's why we have this not so
heavy guitar sound yeah on that album
and guitarists ins so technology plays a
role because that's the same band that
recorded peace of mind right yeah in
terms of in terms of players but they're
they're doing things differently and so
let's let's jump into something that
people have asked about in in this class
and in many other places it's sort of
the paradigm for these these questions
but it actually only applies to certain
certain bands and that's the ship of
theseus example right I think we're
mostly all familiar with this if we're
not you know as soon as I talk about it
you're gonna recognize that it comes up
in Plutarch in his life of Theseus but
Plato had talked about something quite
similar in the symposium in terms of the
mind and the body and all these sorts of
things and the idea is so that the Ship
of Theseus takes off and over time every
single part on that ship gets replaced
but none of it gets replaced all at once
so you know you can think of a crappy
car that you have that you buy and you
know first of the wheels go and get rid
of them put new ones
eventually the transmission goes get rid
of that I mean you can't get rid of
maybe you can get rid of everything I
don't know but you have to imagine doing
that and how is this apply to bands well
you hand bands where there are no
original members and you know I
mentioned menudo is where it's like part
of their their business strategy is to
do that but I think in a lot of cases it
just happened because nobody expected
these bands to be around forty years
later and they they had to swap parts in
and swap parts out those parts being
people so I have a number of questions
that are that are kind of connected with
this one is we'll think about well is a
band with no original members still that
that's a band the Ship of Theseus
problem but we'll also talk about cases
where there's one original member left
because some of them I think we would
say yes and some of them perhaps we'd
say no we can also think about bands
where they have a breakup and then
because metal became big and profitable
again later on they reformed is it the
same band or isn't this the same band
you know like bands like Raven we can
say well they're definitely the same
band but some of these bands that
reconstituted themselves because they
could play it walk it and make a block I
don't know and then another I think
another really interesting question to
think about is when we've got two rival
versions of the same band which is which
is the band right it's sort of like that
thing that that popped up all the time
and shows in the 1970s and 1980s where
someone's evil twin would show up and
you can always tell by the goaty goaty
would be going on and you know somebody
have to shoot the right one well which
one is that you know which Saxon is it
which Queens right is it which rap so
we're going to get into those and then
there's one other question that I think
is is is really interesting that comes
out of just the thinking about identity
in metaphysical terms and that's if you
take away certain members does the band
quit being a band and I think the van
Halen case is kind of like that is David
Lee Roth is essential enough to
that you take him away and it's no
longer the band I guess the answer is no
right but consider another case what if
you took the Scorpions
and took Rudolf Schenker out of the band
would it still be the Scorpions I'm
tempted to say no because he's the the
main songwriter he's the one who formed
the band held it together I think he is
the only original member left of the
band as well and then there's a few
other questions that we can bring up as
well and and here's here's where I'm
gonna I'm gonna put out a proposal I
don't have this completely thought out
Scott might call me on it and say that's
nonsense or anything you might as well I
think that the focus on original members
might be a bit misplaced I think that we
might need to talk and I'm not really
happy with this term so I mean you know
ecstatic to hear a better term than this
but I want to talk about essential
members ones who became central to the
band at a certain point in time
sometimes they will be original members
so if we think about Motorhead Lemmy was
both an original and an essential member
if we think about Iron Maiden Steve
Harris is both a original and essential
member but I would go so far as to say
that at this point in time Bruce
Dickinson is also an essential member so
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
let's let's talk about the Ship of
Theseus then first so what are some
bands in which we have no original
members first one that comes to mind for
me is Thin Lizzy you know Phil Lynott
long-dead Brian Robertson long gone Gary
Moore well he's dead too
the only person who's you could say mint
condition from some version of the band
is Scott Gorham so is Thin Lizzy you
know which which sometimes does tour as
Thin Lizzy instead of as Black Star
riders is Thin Lizzy an actual original
continuing band or what what do you
think Scott
well Tim Ulysses an interesting example
because John Sykes is still around
and he was in Finland Phil and it's well
first of all let's talk about original
and essential the fact that Phil's gone
he is some some names were synonymous
right so uh he is Thin Lizzy right let
was Motorhead you know although you know
you you you can't just be I mean even
Gary Moore right where it's a solo act
Gary Morris gotta have a bassist and a
drummer and it's about because it's a
name that's true but I you know I don't
I wouldn't call it Thin Lizzy I'm more
comfortable with them calling themselves
something else well Vivian Campbell
wasn't Thin Lizzy for a while yeah from
yeah and that's why they when they make
new music they do it as Black Star
riders
yeah and I'm okay with that when they
tour is Thin Lizzy all they do is play
The Thin Lizzy catalog I know and I
would say that's a nice tribute okay so
they're a tribute band rather than
actually being the band band yeah I mean
I like that so uses useful distinction
to make so what we've got is I mean cuz
there is continuity there I mean Scott
Gorham it's not like Thin Lizzy you know
went off the seen him and then
reimbursed right I mean well actually
they did break up after L field shall I
not died but then they they come back
together with Scott Gorham was the
bandleader it would it would give more
validity if John Sykes jumped into okay
we we would be adding a another member
that was in the band with Phil but then
again I have to say it would just be a
more heartfelt tribute okay when Gary
Moore did the concert for Phil he did a
DVD years ago and I would say that's as
much of a tribute as somebody calling
themselves so so this is one that we you
and I have talked about quite a bit
Hisss has brought up the idea and it's
basically gene Simmons and Paul Stanley
bringing up the idea since they already
have Tommy Thayer and Eric Carr in the
make up basically doing you know ace and
Peter Criss right that they would find
people to replace gene Simmons and Paul
Stanley oh they're getting pretty old
Paul Stanley's voice is starting to go
gene Simmons probably wants to like you
know I don't count his money or
something he doesn't have enough time to
do that and or you know talk trash about
people start a blog so they're talking
about essentially franchising it and
finding two people to be on stage to
replace them and they would be the
official kiss but it would have none of
the original members you said before
that that would just be a tribute band
it is but but if it's if it's being
licensed by them does that change
anything no I have a friend I think I
told you Fleetwood Mac has licensed an
official Fleetwood Mac tribute that
tours the world and so to my friends
from Liverpool
one is the Christine McVie the others
the Lindsey Buckingham and we've gone
out to see them and before Mick
Fleetwood there's a big-screen mix
liquid said these are my friends
you know and I'm sure that mcflip was
getting a percentage of but but there
even though they're licensed by the real
Fleetwood Mac there's still a tribute
band I mean and their job is to try to
make it sound just like the record not
like the live versions like you know he
said what he got like stems from the
producers to play live with the band and
they even go back to the Peter Green
stuff so yeah so they would just be
licensing and it would be a kiss tribute
band that gene is still collecting money
from and Paul probably gets a little bit
oh I'm home I'm sorry yeah yeah so they
would split it 50/50 I mean in other
words Gene's pretty much just figuring
out a way to make money when he doesn't
want to be on the road anymore because
that's if I mean know it so that's an
interesting that's an interesting idea
because other bands might pick up on the
same model you know and let's talk about
another one that's out there should we
consider it to be the same band I'm
gonna say no and it's Quiet Riot the it
does it does have one what we could call
a central member left Frankie Banali the
drummer but there are no original
members left in the band Frankie Banali
wasn't an original member of Quiet Riot
I'm not even sure we can consider him an
essential member of Quiet Riot in goo
Satan who's singing you know I don't I
don't know I was looking it up earlier
and it was all people I don't I don't
know well that's that's the ethos I mean
sometimes a front person well it's like
the David Lee Roth thing let's just go
back to that you mentioned in your
introduction Sammy Hagar and Sammy Hagar
and David Lee Roth ethos entirely
different as front people the the image
has changed you know Oh completely
different because they both like to
party okay that's clear but the party in
different ways you know that Sammy Hagar
could party fairly responsibly you know
I mean I when I saw them when they when
they actually went on concert with the
first tour it was Michael Anthony who
was like chugging you know Jack whiskey
all the guy kept playing maybe it was
fake or something like that but David
Lee Roth was definitely an ethnos he was
like mr. hedonist you know exactly he
was mr. self-importance
look at me he's actually a bright guy a
Purdham speak but he has that he was
just like you know almost noncoherent
not really with it but like you know
sharp or form or kind of a goof yeah
and he took his job a little more
seriously it seemed but yeah that held
in Connolly we still need to be the the
party Kings right well here's an
interesting thing from Bruce with van
Hagar and a lot that's a good point a
lot of people did start calling it van
Hagen
the lyrics became simplified and and in
some respect they became less raw you
know you think about some of the stuff
I'm like you know van Halen won or fair
warning that's some pretty raw stuff
even Van Halen - with dead or alive you
know I mean it was definitely more raw I
mean of course van hagar took on
different subjects I mean right now got
a little political with the idiot and
David Lee Roth whose would have never
done that I don't think I've never heard
him do anything political or yeah I
can't nothing comes to mind the subject
matter did change though the lyrics
subject matter did yeah that first album
5150 was a shock I remember buying it
behind the tape and putting it in my
mom's car what is this you know I didn't
know if I was appointed or what but I
did like it in its own way but I was
like this isn't van Halen
yeah but you have a new writer a new
front person a new singer yeah quite
true yeah oh I'm sorry I wanted to say
Bruce also said something cool about
Queen oh yeah and you know there's a lot
of controversy but freddie's gone and
there's nothing we can do about that and
I'm I never got a scene with Freddie but
Adam was fantastic the times I've seen
oh and I got to see Bryan may play
guitar close to me which was and you
know it's the band you know it's him in
Roger you know so that's I do want to
track I want to shift the conversation
to talk about this essential members
idea but that reminds me of something
else listening to an interview on NPR
about the possibility of a whole reunion
you know what's left of the who right
and and and try to remember who it was
it wasn't who's talking so this is not
possible we can't get along yeah
and I think there's he also said one
other thing that I thought was really
brilliant which is when we when we do
when we were touring we'd get to play
maybe 13 songs out of our catalogue why
the hell would we want to add any new
songs to a catalogue that we already
don't get to play most of the time and
but this not being able to get a long
thing you know this relational aspect of
it a band is a unity right and a unity
only works when the band members can
actually be on the same page you know
sometimes that's why we were talking
about super groups often don't work or
even groups that have big egos like you
think about the split in doc and between
Don doc and himself very talented you
know sort of you know came up with in
the the rock and metal thing and George
Lynch who had to leave and do the lynch
mob word kiss you know Ace Frehley
really couldn't stay in kiss didn't help
that he was like high and drunk all the
time
I think even if he hadn't done that I
don't think he could have stayed in in
kiss and so you know it's not just
enough to have the the members they have
to be able to function or you you can't
really have the unity of a band
I mean van Halen provides us with some
sad examples of that with the the van
Halen brothers ostracizing Michael
Anthony for not breaking quickly enough
with Sammy Hagar I find that you know
really quite quite sad yeah no I agree
but let's talk about this this idea of
essential members and that'll lead us
into the one original member thing so I
think that we can talk about essential
members who come on to replace earlier
original members and then become a
central part of the band so you know for
example in Iron Maiden they went through
a number of different guitarists and
singers dave murray is really close to
the origin of the band but he wasn't the
first guitarist right I think he's an
essential member yeah I think Paul
Di'Anno thought he was an essential
member and then became no longer an
essential member so you know
then he was replaced by somebody who I
think is arguably an essential member
and that's that's Bruce Dickinson and so
you know we could look at other examples
I think deep purple provides us with
another classic case
Ian Gillan is he is he a original member
of deep purple no he replaced I don't
even remember the name of the first
singer but he wasn't he wasn't great he
wasn't Gillan Gillan and the mark to
line up is is the paradigmatic version
of the band and I think we can say some
people are more essential than others so
you know a great example is you know we
talked about Motorhead a little bit
earlier Lemmy is at his original and
absolutely essential you can't have
Motorhead without Lemmy Fast Eddie
Clarke really important and you know but
at the band went on after him Brian
Robertson never became an essential
member because he didn't really get
along with anybody and he was kind of a
weird you know addition you know virtual
essential member and and we can I think
we can say this with with other things
as well what makes somebody essential so
here's where I want to I'm gonna turn it
over to Scott as well because I want to
throw three things in your lap I want to
suggest that the people who have maybe
the biggest claim are the band leaders
people like Steve Harris the songwriters
who may not be the same as the band
leaders but you know often oftentimes do
coincide and then the front manner front
women who again may not be the same
Steve Harris is not a frontman of Iron
Maiden you know he's perfectly willing
to let the other guys I mean runs around
on stage a lot but but he's willing to
let the other guys do it because he's
confident enough so here's so here's my
question for you is that an adequate
sort of breakdown of who is probably the
most essential where am i leaving
something out
I mean I guess we can also kind of
discuss things that are behind the
scenes that as fans we might not know
about so it's fans say well this is a
maker break for me if this person is not
in the band they're not the band anymore
and you're right you know so Steve
Harris is not only a major songwriter
but he's kind of like the organizer he's
calle you know he's he really he kicks
in the early years of the van he was
like you know you're out here yeah and
he was he's very much the one that kind
of organizes stuff I mean he's you know
I'm sure everybody in the band has a say
but let's say there's somebody in the
band that's not a big songwriter but
keeps the band together and keeps being
sane or getting along but they're not a
songwriter
you had mentioned there's people behind
the scenes too like managers how to fit
in well so from the other side maybe if
you asked the band who the essential
people are they might have different
answers I mean they might agree with you
and then they would say but also
so-and-so if it wasn't for them like you
know they're always on time they always
make sure we're on time or that could be
you know you hear them tip their hat to
the management who takes care of you
know if we think of spinal tap he really
hears a really interesting point by
Chris I want to see what you make of
this there are no essential numbers only
essential albums
well essential albums does that mean the
members that played on those albums are
the important people or the albums
themselves no matter how they're played
or who they're played by live I guess I
don't understand I guess there the focus
would be on the catalog right and and
and then sort of the transformation of
that catalog if you still are touring
into setlists so you could you could
have anybody so let's take a def leppard
comes to mind
yeah so I'm a big high and dry and
pyromaniac fan when hysteria came out
that was their huge album and one of my
big criticisms with them is 30 years
later they're still playing the same set
they did in 1988 even when they have new
records they don't represent the new
album on the tour yeah so that's
interesting yeah and you know of course
Steve Clark passed in the 90s but you
know it's kind of you've got pretty much
the original band for the most part but
Phil Collen argues because Phil Collen
didn't really start contributing till
hysteria so Phil Collen wasn't part of
the band he did one solo in pyromania
and he wasn't on high and dry at all so
to him he's created this new sound which
was hysteria he was part of that new
sound and the stuff that came before
like gone through the night he wasn't
part of yeah and so that's an essential
album I think many would say even if
it's not my favorite but also now we
have this new guitar player that's
contributing this new way guitar is
playing texture or the way the music
sounds and then they go back and play
some of the high and dry stuff and it's
not as convincing that's interesting
yeah in order to be able to play I mean
and you could say something similar to
so we've seen Judas Priest four times in
the last ten years and when when they
play some of the the classic stuff so
I'll say stuff from like 83 backwards
it's like dead-on you know like victim
of changes for example but then they'll
also play some of the stuff and you know
I think it's Rob Halford influence he
really does like that you know like the
drumming where it's way too much
drumming you know and it's like it's
like a very it seems very heavy but it
kind of loses some of the heaviness and
you're like I wish you would have played
this song a little bit closer to through
the original not as if you're in a 1990s
[Music]
thrash band or something like that you
know and so I think that I think we can
see similar things going on now that
said we don't want to say well musicians
you know when they come into concert
they must play exactly the way they did
in 1980 ridiculous and I want I want to
go back to something I was gonna stop
you at the beginning you said something
very interesting that we shouldn't blow
over not track from it but you said what
about the bands that break up but then
get back together when it's kind of oh
yeah yeah so but is that the same band I
mean not not to take it too far out it
could be the all the original members
but the album they did they were in the
early 20s hedonist below and now they're
responsible is also they don't have that
is still forgot so going to bed at nine
o'clock yeah and so is the music coming
across like that I mean is it coming you
know and like people say well why don't
you write like that first album and a
lot of these issues because I'm not 18
anymore yeah you know so there's a
certain degree that albums are snapshots
okay yeah yeah that's that's a good way
to put it sort of like a chunk of that
time you know and you can't really get
it back and if heard bands play the
older stuff and it's great but it
doesn't have that same you know but the
new stuff really sounds me like I saw
Robert Plant and he did the whole new
record and it was unbelievable and he
was smart out choosing the Zeppelin
songs he but you know there's a couple
things that's like I don't need to hear
you because you you don't sound like
that anymore you can't it's not that raw
it's not that raw kind of like young and
rebellious and you know it was a
different era the late 60s or early 70s
you know times were rent and you were a
kid and now you're in your 70s and
learned a lot you know I wonder - the
response from the audience we could say
has changed over time as well you know I
mean you go to some some metal shows and
it's all people everything it's not all
and there are some younger people but
it's all people our age you know an
older you know right see except and
Ravin at the Gramercy in New York City
an old guy there who had to be like 80
and a long white hair like almost down
to his waist he was super skinny and you
know just head banging and stuff like
that we're all looking at him like wow
this guy's really something you know
that I don't think he would have seen
him in in you know when except was
playing in 1983 oh don't you it's funny
you could say that as we've been going
to concerts people have always been our
age yeah I suppose I mean it's also this
is a whole different topic that we might
talk about you know in terms of
generations next time one of the things
that is really cool about going to
concerts is seeing like parents there
with their kids or younger people and
seeing this this this love for a certain
kind of music getting getting passed
down along with the lore of legends and
you know all the other stuff I want to
come back to the some some of the stuff
that we were gonna discuss though
another thing we can talk about is bands
where there's only one original member
is it still the same band and I think it
really depends on the member
so like uriah heep with mick box I would
say is still the same band but that's
because they've brought in people over
time who maintain the continuity Iron
Maiden has only one original member of
Steve Harris Judas Priest has only one
original member who you know in Hill but
in those cases there's essential members
that came in and I think you could say
the same thing with Uriah Heep now
there's been a little bit of discussion
about Black Sabbath in there and I think
this is an interesting one Tony Iommi's
Black Sabbath seven star I guess you
could say that
is it a Black Sabbath album you only
didn't want it to be he wanted it to be
a solo band and the record company and I
forget who it was at the time made him
say it was a Black Sabbath album is it a
Black Sabbath album he doesn't really
seem to consider it as such but then you
know later on the next album after it
[Music]
you know the eternal Idol where he
brings Bob Daisley and on bass it's kind
of Sabbath you know and I think it was
it was a
here's who was singing that that one was
it or was a Tony Tony Martin no actually
I don't
yesterday that but you know Whitesnake
you could also say is a only one
original member and and Whitesnake you
know Whitesnake is almost kind of a solo
band just not called the David Coverdale
band because when we get to these bands
that are actual solo acts it's not an
issue if you know if Ozzy shuffles
people in and out
nobody cares right because it's still
Aussie if do does that that's fine for
him is Whitesnake still Whitesnake when
you know you mentioned Chris Sykes right
bringing him in does that change the
band I don't think so it does change the
the sound but it's still one guy who's
really running the show and that he then
John leaves after the the essential
album and then yeah why comes in who I
thought was a really bad choice
Vanderburgh comes in handy Burke comes
and Vivian Campbell comes out and yeah I
mean you're right that's an example of
where I was calling kind of like
Motorhead is Lemmy oh wait is David
Coverdale you know that brings up so
Motorhead spin-off right think about
Fast Eddie Clarke and fast way now that
was going to bring in Pete way and then
he had contractual arrangements that he
couldn't he couldn't get out of and so
they they brought in a different basis
is fast way Fast Eddie Clarke and then
whoever the hell else he can surround
himself with maybe because he's the only
person that I didn't us remember from
the man and I wanted to talk about one
great example of where this didn't work
at all Bobby blots are in Wrath right
so Bobby Blaster is an original member
is a drummer oh and you know for a while
he was touring under the name of rat but
but you know he couldn't he couldn't
really pull it off and people were like
um this isn't you know you're the
drummer and it'd be different
I think if it were other
a drummer but I don't think his
contribution was sufficient enough right
- really really sustain that I mean well
now you're talking about essential
members
I always thought Warren Demartini so
important but uh well I
so let's let's actually jump into rival
bands then you and I have talked a lot
about this particular example often when
we have rival bands it turns into a
lawsuit right because who's going to be
able to use the band name and the
lawsuit in the case of rat decided that
Bobby Blosser didn't get to use rat and
instead rat with three original members
Warren - martini on guitar supplemented
with Carlos Cavazos oh and then Juan
Croce ER and Steven Percy who are the
vocals and and the bass because there's
two singers - rat and the rat sound they
they were the band now I saw them in
concert and you know they were they're
pretty good
I I thought it was quite amazing how
well they came together and I loved
seeing how they incorporated Carlos
Chavez Oh who's good friends with Warren
de martini into that band and made him
part of that unity yeah when they kicked
out warm de martini and then Carlos
Cavazos like screw you guys I'm out of
here
I was only here for Warren you know we
still have two original members the two
vocalists and the the bassist but it
doesn't feel like ran you know they
surrounded themselves with a bunch of
young who knows who these guys are who
might might have been in rat you know
tribute bands for all I know I have a
hard time taking that seriously as as
rad and it's it's you know it's kind of
sad because I really do like you know
Juan Crozier as a bassist and I like the
rat sound but I don't think you can go
and see rat anymore what did your take
no I feel the same way like I remember
it might have been the late 90s or
whatever rat was playing and Warren
sounded great
it was the band maybe the early 2000s
but no I agree you can't really see
rapped you can't really you know no it's
it's done but here's here's a question I
have for you something that we keep kind
of dipping into what it what is the
criteria when these bands go it's a
court what are the ethics involved in
the judge deciding you know like what is
the criteria the judge is using first
here's where it gets really complicated
because some of these cases are in
American courts and some are in British
courts and I even all guys have looked
at the report rulings I've only looked
at like you know articles that talk
about the decision so it would be
interesting to see what's you know
whether it was like good legal reasoning
or just kind of made up on the fly
because I think that part of it is is
like thinking about who's who is more
essential but they also do have to look
at like in the case of rap they had a
covenant that they'd signed together
back like in the early days when they're
all living in one apartment yeah right
and so that that played a role in it if
I remember right another great example
is Saxon where there were two rival
Saxons and this guy decided by I think a
trademark court or something in in
Britain Graham Oliver who was original
member but who'd been really kind of
screwing up got kicked out of the band
started took over the name started
billing him his band as Saxon me and
when I lift my firt and the rest of the
band and an Oliver's replacement they
were touring a Saxon and then they got
sued by Graham Oliver Saxon and then the
the court found in favor of Biff Byford
so now Graham Oliver not still tours as
like Graham Oliver Saxon I think he may
have another original guy with him not
to and this is this is sort of a
technique that people use so Bobby
Blosser can say Bobby blot sirs wrath
you know not well that's it such a
Dennis DeYoung sticks
um what I think this is interesting
because I feel like we're discussing it
as fans like what criteria is as fans so
I'd be curious maybe this is some
research I'll do my own what is the
criteria in legal ethics or you know
what I mean what is so if we had a judge
here that entertains these cases would
they say well this is what's important
yeah mark has a good comment here about
this best advice I ever received as an
artist always make sure your contracts
are started before you put up any
creative content especially these days I
I think but you know when people get
together they often don't want to do
that right at the start because they're
they're so into others we're gonna make
some great music together and you know
there's that whole sort of informality
to things the the contract thing is
interesting but I will say something
that any contract could be challenged
because of changing circumstances so you
can sign something and then 10 years
later well yeah you know Your Honor we I
signed that but that's before I knew
so-and-so was gonna go out and destroy
property and run out all these bills and
people and you know like you would have
a change in circumstances that then
would kind of kill the contract I mean I
yeah a lot cracks are challenged all the
time so that's it's interesting though
although just so you know what an artist
does to protect our music is let's say I
write an album and some of you might
know this already I'll submit all my
music so those Library of Congress and
get a number then I go to ASCAP which
I'm a member of which is like my you
know my publishing and so I put down
that I own a hundred percent of my
writing a hundred percent of my
publishing there's no gray area there
that's not so much a contract so I think
more than contracts if you write as a
band you better
register who gets what percentage and
that stays and black that's pretty black
or white but that's how but that's how
it would work like you know van Halen
always said we all wrote it so we they
all wouldn't complain about money right
well that was that was one of the big
complaints that Michael
than he had was that he was essentially
being like pushed into being treated
just as a hired hand you know that the
van Halen brothers were kind of pushing
everybody else out so yeah now one one
band that has actually managed to pull
it off and have what we can call rival
bands but do so in a less acrimonious
way is tank and you know you could say
if anybody deserves to be called tank
it's algae wort because he's the only
original member by the time that the
other two guys who have the other tank
Chris Evans and I think Nick Tucker you
know before he was working with these
two brothers when tank was a threesome
the Brad's brothers and algae Ward now
the reason why algae board left tank in
not not just from being in a sort of a
cantankerous guy apparently he's got
some health problems we can't do a lot
of touring and stuff like that so he
still produces tank stuff though where
he is the whole band he plays the bass
he does the singing he does the drums he
does the guitar you know in his home
studio and puts out albums every once in
a while most recent being if I remember
right the t34 into the pit the other
tank the one that's actually touring and
has her if I if I'm not mr. member
Doogie white as the singer who's like
bounced around from band to band back
ever since rainbow days is is evans and
tucker who were in the most important
tank album honor which was so the hades
that i would say is probably the
definitive tank album as some of their
biggest hits on it and and they they're
both producing albums and they you know
one tours i don't know if they actually
pay algae ward anything i don't know if
the arrangements are but they're they're
they're not like fighting with each
other about like who gets to call
themselves tank well and that's we're
registering the material you'll get
money although it's gray area with
technology these days so if he's home
writing sick
and then they play an ASCAP Venues you
should be getting checks because it's
his music you mean like when they're
when they're playing classic tank stuff
on tour well you know it we example of
him writing the music because he has
health problems like by himself
well it wasn't right for the the other
tank he writes just for himself right
and then he produces that and that album
comes out you know and then they they've
they've the other tank has brought out
and at least one new album in that time
as well but when they're on tour much
much of their catalog is older tank
stuff you know yeah and any kind of
sales with download sales some he'll you
should be getting checks but Morrell he
should I wonder if he has a merch
agreement but like definitely there his
song so if they're sold or being
licensed out the check just shows up in
the mail yeah from BMI or ASCAP probably
not gonna be that big of a deal unless
you know he manages to get Geico to
bring tank and next well that's the sad
reality of where we are now yeah unless
you yeah unless you sell it to Geico to
use that maybe that'll license it that
that'll be so there's there's one other
rival band one that I want to get your
take on and we'll you know see what
everybody else thinks about it as well
and then we'll like switch to the
answering questions thing so we got
Judas Priest right and they have two
young guys relatively young guys as
their guitarist who replaced the
original Glenn Tipton and KK downing and
Glenn Tipton he's cool with that KK
downing not so cool he wanted to come
back to Priest after having left Priest
and focused mostly on a golf course
which he bought and managed and I guess
didn't go all that well and he's still
bit by the the playing bug so he has
formed a new band which is called KK
downing Priest now that's clearly you
know an attempt to try to ride on
I think just like you know Paul Di'Anno
did with with Iron Maiden stuff that's
right
and now here's where it gets really
interesting so KK downing you know he
he's you know he's an essential member
in some respects he was really important
to the sound when it was him and Glenn
Tipton he's also brought in les Binks
who was one of priests drummers for
quite a while and here's where it gets
more complicated he brought in as a
vocalist Tim Ripper Owens who replaced
Rob Halford on those albums that people
aren't quite sure whether they're Priest
albums or not you know so do we have a
rival priest here or do we have
something that's kind of a weird you
know hybrid or cyborg thing that I'm not
sure what to call it it's not a tribute
band I know
no that's interesting so bands along the
way have different members in it in
different eras now if those ex members
got together yeah rival band well that's
interesting
well Marc Marc says it's a self tribute
and Chris says it's a schism that's
great Protestant band yeah you know I
guess the the test to me is am I gonna
buy a ticket to see KK downing Greece
oh that's interesting a very pragmatic
test and no I mean maybe if I was a huge
KK downing fan they'd let me let me sort
of sweet in this deal
so let's say it's in blastn and they
actually did cross the pond which most
bands don't do these days because it's
it you know it's cost so much in fuel
and they're gonna be playing and it's
they're playing at some place and it's
like $10 tickets would you go yeah you
know I would go because I am curious
yeah I would and you know I got now what
would you pay 25 bucks
this sounds like the game she used to
play in high school like alright let's
sweeten the deal like when will you
agree to this when I paid 25 bucks yeah
I wouldn't I mean if it was like you
know right near Berkeley there's a
Lansdowne Street and yeah you know but
no it's it's kind of where the Red Sox
Stadium is but it's also a strip of
clubs okay so it's a it's a bunch of
feet like the House of Blues is there
access was there Avalon and so I walk by
these to get to the train now so if I'm
walking and it's 25 bucks to get in
you're only going that way okay it would
be you know it would I would be curious
because I'm sure it would be a good band
walking you're walking along the door
and you haven't seen the marquee and
suddenly you hear like you know the
chords for some heads are gonna roll
coming out of the door oh well that that
would get me in cuz that's such a great
riff yeah you know he was part of that
but I know it's kind of an interesting
thing but I do kind of I have an
unpopular it's funny this subject
because I'm an unpopular view of I don't
like tribute bands right now we're
talking okay interesting why not I mean
it's it's kind of an interesting night
but for a musician to like spend all
their time directly copying another band
and then the fact that these bands are
getting Bruce Dickinson jokes that he'd
be bent know as a Bruce Dickinson no it
was Jeff Tate said he'd be better off
joining a Queens right tribute band then
then going around to himself because
people seem to want to go see these
tribute bands more than the real bands
that's interesting that's probably
something that we need to do a show on
actually the notion of tribute band and
and what's going on with it there was
some musician I don't remember who who
had a story about trying out for a
tribute band that was of his band and
they they they didn't believe that he
good enough but he didn't sound enough
like himself I don't have to track down
that story because that would definitely
fit into like the notion of is a tribute
band essentially like a copy and what's
going on there now Chris has a funny
remark here define yourself as a true
fan pay any price they want the essence
so if you really like creased and KK
downing is part of it well then you
should be willing to pay a hundred bucks
for tickets you know
oh yeah ticket prices are a whole other
yeah that's another thing we could talk
about some time but let's um let's start
addressing some of the questions Bruce
has to take off so thanks for being here
Bruce there's I know there's a lot of
stuff in here that we want to get to so
I'm gonna scroll up and find some of the
things that we probably missed that
could be interesting to to address so
Andy had something at the very start
where she said I think there's some
bands like Sabbath where there are
versions of the band that keep their
Athos and more successfully then there's
other bands where critical players are
lost like ac/dc metallica where the
band's maintained a sort of pre-post
identity okay so like bond so yeah and
Brian Johnson or you know Cliff Burton
and Jason Newsted and I would say that
with a like the Cliff Burton that's
because Cliff Burton was a songwriter
you know you know he was so of so
essential there then there are bands
where major changes are made like except
where there isn't any kind of arguing
over identity judo is still you know
there's a great example in sings except
songs in concert but Marc Tornillo still
a great new voice and then there's bands
like priests where there's era Halford
Owens back to hell from her fans simply
accept the difference because they have
to right but then there's the bands that
keep touring under a name or even fight
for the name in various iterations it
feels more like a claim to fame and not
a musical shift or a claim to money you
know cleaned of money yeah so except as
an interesting one because when Widow
left
if they wanted to be jerks about it they
could have said you can't sing any of
our our old stuff but they didn't do
that instead they sort of like said good
luck buddy
sing whatever you want and you know we
are kind of fortunate in that for a
while we had after except like reformed
both judo and except out there touring
around you know doing doing except stuff
who'da was doing all of his own stuff -
and then except had their newer albums
as well but but except really has turned
into just the - you know a ball tastes
and and Wolfe Hoffman and it seems like
they haven't been able to get along
either and so I don't I don't think
there's much as far as I know right now
it seems like except is kind of dead in
the water yeah I do like what Andy says
a lot because I guess I was leaning
towards this before you have a new band
well like we could go back to the van
Halen example the good news is he wasn't
trying to be Roth they weren't trying to
write the same stuff so it was a new era
it was and then the music from there on
out became you know the the new sound of
Van Halen Van Halen because the to Van
Halen brothers are in it Eddie's playing
is Eddie's playing
it's the Phil Collen thing with Def
Leppard yeah I didn't like when hysteria
came out but he did invent this new song
that catapulted them up and to like
number one status and even though that
was a big change after what four albums
he became masti leopard with a different
sound but this whole thing about the the
you know with a Bon Scott thing of of
course was with ac/dc and yeah it
changes but I think it keeps the
integrity I mean a CDC kept the
integrity the muse of the music it was
to the same themes drinking and whoring
and beating people up and stuff like
that they didn't compromise that many
any of those angles
and an interesting one too we found
essential people not to jump around but
I guess these things pop up you know Led
Zeppelin ended when John Bonham died
yeah and rightly so and I think there's
there can be some cases where you simply
can't replace the person who goes like I
don't think Iron Maiden can be Iron
Maiden without Steve Harris no I agree
even if you like trains his kid who's a
basis to take his place I think it works
it's like Wolfgang and Van Halen his son
plays bass but certainly Michael Anthony
is a very distinctive voice and the
courses of those songs his plane people
put him down but listen to those albums
he's panned to one side he said sounds
great and um he had a unique voice and a
personality let's talk about the
personality of someone like him on stage
yeah you know now here's here's another
one from Marc from much earlier on a
scotch responds suggest that bands don't
have the final say on their own identity
that identity rests primarily with the
audience that's kind of an interesting
idea the audience and let's say maybe
the fan base you know maybe there's like
decisions that get made kind of on Moss
let's think about the rant one right so
so Steven Percy and Juan Croce air our
stay they got these three young guys
with them and they're out there they
have you know the Facebook thing and the
Twitter and they're the Rat Pack and all
that stuff and we're we're still we're
the fan base we're like yeah guys we
don't buy it so so maybe there is
something to that and you know to go
back to the there's there's some
discussion in there about Black Sabbath
there were some people who were like
this is not the same band you know Ozzy
go on you know do singing I think they
did manage to to integrate do in there
and then you know there's more changes
too because right Bill Ward leaves and
and Vinny Appice is now the drummer so
now you've just got Tony Iommi and
geezer butler but the
introduction of these guys really
revitalized Black Sabbath I mean you
listen to the mob rules it is you know I
mean compare that to never-say-die you
know it's it's it's it's not a new band
in the sense of like brand new but it's
it's a new era for first that's it yeah
I totally agree now it's funny about the
the ethos image thing I don't you know
will consider six a classic rock prog
band from the 70s but I saw the in the
90s and it was the original members but
of course Chuck Panozzo was diagnosed
with AIDS and couldn't or they got this
young guy that dressed up like a hipster
from the 90s and with his bass really
low he looked like somebody that would
be in Green Day and they hired this kid
because they were thinking well this
looks gonna really bring in the young
crowd and we're going I don't buy this
get this guy off aid yeah yeah you know
it's interesting cuz that again
I brought up the Brian Robertson thing
you know who had been within Lizzy and
then when fast city Clark leaves
Motorhead and if Anthony Clark leaves
Motorhead because he feels the band has
lost its way and it's no longer the same
band that they started with because
Lemmy is doing duets with you know when
do Williams and getting too close to
girls school and all of that sort of
yeah the fast that he leaves and they
bring in this guy Brian Robertson and
you know if you got a five piece band
you I think you have a lot more room for
like bringing in a new member who
doesn't quite fit but when it's your
lead guitarist in your only guitarist
and he you know the other two guys are
dressed like you know how you know denim
jackets and leather and long hair and
stuff like that and Robertson is coming
on and biking shorts the other thing
that was that was really central to is
Robertson refused to play earlier stuff
he said we're gonna play what's on
another perfect day the album that I and
and another perfect day is a great album
sure but he didn't want to play the
older Motorhead stuff so he's like
forcing a a division right there and the
fans did not like it you know they were
like who
hell is this guy and he was only there
for one album before the hell out of
there well that's interesting you know
and I felt like now you saw the 5150
tour but when the yeah yes of that came
out there was only one Kree there was
only one Roth tune in the set which was
interesting because I kind of felt like
Sammy Hagar came in and said no no old
Van Halen
now do you remember them not playing
rock stuff I don't you know it we
shouldn't we should actually take a look
at the setlist for that what I do
remember is them playing quite a bit of
Sammy Hagar stuff right
they played at least four of his Tunes
yeah that would be that would be
actually be worth checking out and while
we do while I do that I'm gonna throw
one here for you to just you know play
around with this is from Chris Morrissey
essence the Sabbath remains Black
Sabbath with Ozzy do and Ray Gillen but
it's not Sabbath with Tony Martin or Ian
Gillan and he says controversial take
care on the essence of Sabbath and I'll
just say that I think I think Ian Gillan
you know born-again that that really
does I think that is a sad but you know
we'll see what Scott thinks about about
all that well I look up the setlist for
and look up the setlist um you know the
interesting thing is I you know Iommi's
the central you know most important
member I would think right because well
he came up with these classic riffs
right so I guess the you know it's funny
we'll talk about Sabbath there's the do
Sabbath there's the Ozzy Sabbath but
it's still Sabbath and nobody really
contested it maybe people have a
preference right of the era's but yeah I
maybe this kind of goes back to it's
more and and tell me if I'm getting the
question right maybe it's going back
more towards essential members and like
so Tony Iommi's still writing great
riffs and his guitar tones this
and it's very central to the sound and
gives our Butler's there that geezer
clapping yeah so when you bring in well
you know and deal in Osseo were worlds
apart and vocals yeah
but the sound was you know still heavy
still am I answer the question right I'm
sorry did I miss a an aspect of it I
didn't see it I didn't know I was just
looking for what you're taking on that
is I mean I think this is one of the one
of the things we're probably not going
to have consensus among among Sabbath
fans about what exactly is essential
Sabbath I mean the most exclusive or
inclusive thing would be well any album
they produce is is Black Sabbath I mean
I would even go so the the 13 album that
came out yeah I was not happy with it
you know I heard it while I was on the
road somebody had it yeah but this isn't
going back that far it's or as time
flying for me came out in 2013
oh yes so it's been a while but I was on
the road and somebody had it with them
so in the hotel room I listened to it
and I guess remember feeling
underwhelmed like he was yeah oh it was
like it had the characteristics of
Sabbath but it was kind of like I felt
like they phoned it in yeah
and it was like it's time to put out a
Sabbath album so we could just put one
out and that's funny because maybe I'm
wrong but it just seemed like it seemed
like although the the B takes that they
didn't want to keep on their other
albums and they were left off the
album's first for a good reason
yeah okay so I got the setlist
the only things they did from earlier
van Halen was Panama and I don't I don't
know how they could not do Panama right
they also did you you really got me
which but that's a cover right that's a
king song exactly and then they had
ain't talking about love as their their
last song that they did before the
Encore and ok that kind of makes sense
so they had a bass solo they had a
guitar solo drum
solo I remember there was actually a
period where Eddie Van Halen and Sammy
Hagar traded licks back and forth they
did in one-way rock only one way yeah
cuz they opened with that on that court
in May
that's Amy hey they actually opened with
you really got me on that one
okay I mean they had BTO open for them
to at Alpine Valley and in their their
encore
they played why can't this be love and
then they played Led Zeppelin's rock and
roll God okay so they did that you know
they really it really was a big break in
many respects and that's another thing
we should talk about bands that do tired
cover bar songs in their set
I saw hard luck you know that that that
actually is a great topic I've there are
some bands that do really great cover
songs
Judas Priest is a prime example think
about diamonds and Ross or the one from
spooky tooth what is it what is it it's
a stained class better buy you better
than me you know or green man Alicia you
know they take the stuff and they
transform it right or another band that
I'm really fond of they're coppers is
wasp you know the real me I actually
like that better than the original oh
but you're talking about them I'm
talking about throwaway songs did a live
concert or it's like any bar band like
you throw a rock and roll at the end
it's like I mean you know you could have
you know and I always like oh my god you
could have just been doing this song
when I saw heart last summer they did
five covers and they'd including a
fifteen minute version of comfortably
numb I mean that's that's I'd one of the
heart comeback album or dreamboat Annie
and I'm thinking why are you selling
tickets and you you know they did a Paul
Simon tune they did a and when people
just left yeah you know this is a little
bit off topic and I do want to get that
but Raven when they did their kick
starter campaign to put out
extermination one of the things that
they had for people who contributed the
campaign which which we did is a special
CD called party animals and it's all
covers but it's all covers by you know
the Gallagher brothers and and their
drummer and it's it's quite good you
know it's sort of like Metallica's
garage days re revisited you know where
they picked just the right songs alright
so so there's there's a good joke here
from Chris I don't know if you saw this
yeah now yes tours with Billy Sherwood
or then Bruce said then the band should
be called maybe yes that's a good oh
yeah real quick side story uh I'm
friends with a keyboardist to play with
Allan Holdsworth for years and he's a
huge Rick Wakeman fan and you know he
was with Allan Holdsworth years ago and
they were gonna go backstage and
security said to him no they don't
they're not seeing anybody and and Allan
Holdsworth looks at them goes the knight
yes said no I mean you know like these
are these are music music royalty people
that like weren't getting back so I
funny thing like 13 delivers exactly
what it intends subpar be nostalgia
you're not you're not wrong but I enjoy
it okay but you know it's sad to have to
say that sometimes right I'm gonna
scroll back into the deep cuts there
were some things in here about not
metaphysics oh oh no 360 deals by the
way this is a great point for anybody
that doesn't know what the 360 deals are
these days that's where a live nation
will pay you a huge sum of money like u2
is those 360 deal band this was I think
to an earlier point when we were talking
about who gets what money 360 deals for
some of these huge acts are guaranteed
millions and
just go on the road and don't have to
worry about live nation will worry about
it so the 360 deals of something to be
known at this day who's getting those
and who are the ones that are barely can
afford to go on the road yeah I mean
like when Raven has to do a Kickstarter
to fund an album you know because what
there's no more record labels there's
nobody investing in in but you have
people like Spotify taking a big chunk
of your work besten yeah that's more of
an ethical topic but anyway and that
might be something that we talked about
the changes in the music business over
over time and how that's affected you
know what's what's available so Chris
had a comment the music is the essence
perhaps you need certain members to
create the musical essence members and
music are correlative so that the you
know the music would be what's essential
and then you could say that the
musicians are also causes in that they
are activating something or they are
unfolding something you know and and
sometimes they can only do it together
right I mean it's it's a remarkable that
algae Ward can in fact be tank all by
himself I don't think most musicians can
pull that off you know they need
somebody else to play with
even do who by the way could play all
the instruments and and sometimes would
actually according to you know people
I've talked to would actually like go
over to musicians and say here's how I
want you to play it like you pick up
their guitar and do that or you know go
over to the drums he recognized that you
you're not a band by yourself you have
to have other people to work with
so yes yeah absolutely there are some
keep cousin Alfonso had a thing a band
is rotating session members outside of
metal a lot of contemporary groups like
snarky puppy and ghost no work this way
trying to think of a metal group who may
have done the same where they kind of
run that's very true
yeah but Starkey puppy is a good example
but um why am I forgetting the bass
players name who's the leader it's
pretty much he snarky puppy okay and um
and that's a rotating bit of place well
its trans-siberian
is the is the one that comes to mind
it's definitely heavy metal but it's a
rotation because it's a it's more of a
business than it is a band it's it's
it's kind of a I don't and a seasonal
business as you pointed out you know and
not only that it's kind of a touring
show wrap and you know it's like a it's
a show not like a concert but like an
event that moves around kind of like I
don't want to compare it to a circus but
you know that's that's all that's but
you know what I mean that it's kind of
like it gets different in that way yeah
session yes session players in bands
moving in out you know it's been
acceptable I mean you know rep beach was
in Dokken for a while from winger and it
wasn't George Lynch but you're taking
well-known legends and put it in their
band so somehow that's kind of like wow
doug aldrich is in this band now he's
legit so it's not like I wonder if that
you know I mean or even in the 80s you
look at some of the bands that we talked
about last session and the the Sabbath
purple Nexus and the bands that came out
of that right and they would have some
of their members sometimes like
recording on an album and then you know
that person would have a some job
somewhere else and they they wouldn't be
on the tour they bring somebody else for
the tour you know yeah yep that's true
you always had like the keyboardist off
stage right that was via par
keyboardists they get less respect than
the drummer's you know well Fitz
from Night Ranger was actually Van
Halen's for a while he went on so when
he left back Ranger he was touring with
Van Halen but I think he was off stage
playing keyboards you know I'm the first
do album the guy who played keyboards
and I mean think about whether you could
have rainbow in the dark without the
keyboards right right he was not
actually a full member of the band at
the time it was only on the second album
and afterwards that he was he was
integrated into the band like I said the
poor keyboard players you know oh all
right so somewhere mark has a good
question here what about bands that keep
the same members but change the name
style of the music for example
gravedigger - digger bow-wow bow-wow are
they still the same band just with a
different image or different bands
entirely I'm tempted to say if they're
changing both the name and the style of
music that they've become a different
band even though they have same members
now the good question is when they go on
tour do they play the old stuff oh yeah
yeah or when they go on tour it's like
no this is this band we're not that good
anymore so you're not gonna hear any of
that I mean it reminds me a little bit
about spinal tap when they have the
split and then they do the experiment
with like doing jazz fusion stuff yeah
are they still I mean now of course
they've lost you know one number but are
they as spinal tap a heavy metal band
playing jazz fusion stuff are they
actually the same band I would say yeah
they just they're they've lost their way
you know where the argument backstage
was they were trying to put this
together yeah with that Nigel a lot of
the stuff didn't work like it couldn't
do Stonehenge because the solo and uh
and so Derek small said well that's a
snug five minutes and then and then
anyways he goes you know what we were
gonna do what I've always wanted to do
the Jazz Odyssey and they had no choice
but to go out to the festival and it was
a great movie cuz it was so ridiculous
it was so on the money it was the older
I get and like well it's not funny
that's my life I kind of think that you
know who are they're spoofing in that
part it was actually deep purple you
know really yeah I mean you listen to
some of the stuff that's happening I'm
like storm bringer and you're like okay
I can see where they're getting this
from I mean it's good stuff but it's it
you know half a storm burger is
definitely not heavy metal you know well
you know keep asking Christopher guest's
he's never revealed he's felt that was
your was Nigel after Jeff back nope um
was it Iron Maiden that you're making
fun of no it wasn't he claims in 94 that
some
unnamed British band came into a hotel
and you can see this if you look this up
and he says uh you know the manager goes
where's your base they're checking the
hotels I don't know where's your
basement I've maybe a left at the
airport and um he said I was watching
this for 15 minutes and that's where I
got the idea for the spinal tap thing
Wow yeah he doesn't with the perfect
accent and everything because yeah you
look great British accent but he said it
was a well known band and then the bass
player was so out of it and the manager
is like trying to check them we but he'd
lost to the bass and he wouldn't even
think concerns I got I don't know maybe
it's at the airport I yeah here's here's
a remark from from Alfonso some songs
really do translate differently from
studio to stage the band ages over time
they may play these songs with the
maturity and nuance not present during
the times of recording that's true yeah
that's a that's very and I've heard I've
heard some band views later revisit a
song it's they brought the tempo to
where it feels better right when you're
younger you tend to do faster tempos dro
had to towards the end of his life sort
of step you know a couple couple keys
down he was still powerful but he
couldn't reach those highs and his voice
matured I mean he got better in my
opinion
yeah now another great example of this
that's kind of funny is venom because
when they first started playing they
admittedly were not very talented at
their instruments right and you know if
their first I mean their first album the
production level is so low that you
almost can't tell how bad they are but
there's a you know there's a famous
story where Henry Rollins they you know
I guess Black Flag and met him we're
playing together and Henry Rollins
actually got like in a fight with them
because he's like you guys suck and but
you know they they become better and
better musicians over time so you can
you can well imagine that if they're
playing stuff off like their first three
albums and I think they actually if I
remember it I think there's two Venom's
out there right now - there's a venom
and venom ink oh I didn't know that I
believe so yeah and but but you know
presumably they actually know how to
play quite well
they hadn't actually been playing that
long when they form their band so all
right Chris has a couple remarks
so maybe heavy metal illustrates
temporal essences rather than a temporal
essences not like photonic forms the
Aristotelian notion of essence is needed
to make sense of it all substantial form
versus accidental form Eddy is the
essential member of iron maiden the
eternal Idol is Sabbath with RA Gillen
okay
so my argument ray feeds the substantial
form Tony is an accidental so there's
there's there's something going on but
it's I mean how to put this in sort of
layman's terms what's what's really
essential is is there it's not something
like a platonic form eternal you know
unchanging it is something dynamic and
other people can pick up on it and this
is this is also to steered in a
different direction this is why you can
have tribute bands where they're not
doing anything original but they're
taking the form and the closer they are
in spirit to the band the more
successful it's not just about sounding
just like the band you know yeah all
right we've got a lot of other things
here as well Oh Chris has another
interesting thing about tribute band
recreates the form without the original
matter that that works in terms of
Aristotelian stuff a lot of discussion
of 13 here and oh here's an interesting
one from from mark and you can talk
about this because you've done you know
session work and gig work
I think session musicians don't get the
credit they deserve within a lot of the
metal community scorpions acoustic
covers of their songs are amazing really
did develop the original so two
different different points there but
yeah I mean what do you think about you
know you've been a session musician and
you've also played you know live with a
lot of different not just in metal and
rock but also in our MBA and Jay
what's your take on that
I'm thinking this is this one well you
know the session player thing has
changed because if we go back thirty
years you bought it now maybe at all the
credits in it right
so I played on I have played on I played
on a bunch of albums but one in
particular was kind of a metal album and
I came up with a lot of the parts and I
was really I was paid out right for my
time so it was like X amount of dollars
per session or per tune but I'm since I
was a guitarist on the album so I really
kind of like produce the guitar parts of
the sense that we're going to double
track these and the artist really kind
of let me kind of go with it in
hindsight I should have asked for some
writing credit but now this comes out my
guitar is all over it my parts that I
have created are all over it but my name
is not anywhere yeah so yeah I got paid
for it but you know in the past it would
be like the deal would be like in the
90s when I was doing records it would be
okay you know obviously I get credit in
this album visible credit like you're
gonna put me like down in the tiny print
and and then you pay me for it but
that's kind of a lost thing now is and
then for the live situation well that's
a tough thing if your replay I had
something where I replay skunk Baxter in
this vinyl American violin all-stars and
skunk Baxter as the Doobie Brothers
guitarist and was on all the Steely Dan
records for a time and that was one of
my scariest moments because people pay
tickets to come see this band it's a sea
skunk Baxter not some punk kid like me
although I really I feel like I did a
really good job and people were nice to
me but I was kind of ready for the hey
I'm just doing a job here and you know
what Jay must have put up with when
right when he filled in for Randy Rhoads
after Randy Rhoads died he said it was
brutal and he was kind of like a we
could call him a session player but he
joined Ozzy and yeah and he I mean he'd
been established and he was a Mickey
grad and he'd
I remember I think he played it quiet
riot for a short period - right you
might be right I don't he'd kind of
circulated around the LA scene quite a
bit he what he definitely was but you
know the thing about the session player
thing is yeah we make contributions but
we're not members and that gets
overlooked and yes of people that the
album sold okay downloads but you know I
know it's funny I never got a single
message about my contribution to it
because people that know who contributed
to it yeah so mark says the term gig
economy seems to apply quite literally
in the music industry I think that's
that's that's quite right and then
Alfonzo says also had the thought of
situations where original members are
prevented from touring due to travel
restrictions and oh yeah this I mean
this is something above the present
loudness was supposed to play right here
just you know like 20 miles south of
Milwaukee and something got screwed up
with their visas and the whole tour the
whole American tour was was postponed
and obviously they missed that that
thing but but there are you know if you
have a band with people from different
places that's yeah they could be really
you could have to have a fill in from
somebody from another band and and there
could be medical things as well you know
well yeah I mean the here's an
interesting one and this is a great
photo topic so foreigner only one or
[ __ ] original member the guitarist
what's his name
why am I forgetting his name this is
terrible anyway they were tour with
Night Ranger and I'll remember his name
the original member the guitarist got
very ill so the guitars from Night
Ranger learned the set one night and
filled in ten shows so now you're having
10 shows with no original numbers oh um
why am I forgetting his name me Mick
Jones am i right Mick Jones yeah so was
it was a foreigner had no original
numbers or a Night Ranger at the time no
no a foreigner Oh
had one original member on that group
and that was the guitarist but the
guitarist got very ill so night range at
one of night ranges guitarists had to
fill in the next ten shows so you're
talking ten shows was zero we got Jeff
Jeff Pilson on bass from darken Joe Howe
strong guitar those nights and everybody
else was just a fill and even the singer
I mean Lou Gramm this is no Lou Gramm
and well he was one of the great voices
so like that's that would be interesting
is that the straw that breaks the
camel's back as a fan you bought a
ticket and he don't say no original
members yeah no actually that reminds me
of something Blue Oyster Cult yep buck
Dharma he's the only original member
left right else okay and what's his name
shows up sometimes and performs with
them he left a long time ago but yeah
what's his name the rhythm guitarist and
keyboard as he died but I feel like Blue
Oyster Cult Eric bloom and buck Dharma
those are the essentials they do most of
the writing yeah
if not all the right there the faces in
the band really so you've got but
they're the only two original members
asked you actually Kasim Sultan from
utopia was in that band for a while hmm
which is interesting
yeah and then um what's his name what
was in which I thought was a great fit
Rudy Sarzo oh so he was employ circle
for a good five six years and he was he
was fantastic yeah I mean not somebody
who you'd imagine like his career
trajectory going that way that's
interesting I mean in a way that that
kind of raises the statute Rudy Sarzo
you're like well you could play this you
can also play this kind of stuff over
here and he was great because like they
had an album where Randy Jackson who was
actually a bass player played on this
lawyers of cold album in the early 80s
and they've avoided those songs because
the bass player couldn't play those
parts but Rudy Sarzo could so all of a
sudden
I'm here in the setlist and loved it you
know it's like songs we would have never
heard buck sitting again you know I
think it would be interesting because we
should wrap this up pretty soon to do a
show about like the the people who
migrated around from from band to band
making important contributions you know
think about basis right Rudy Sarzo is a
good example bob days Lisa you know
prime example right and I wonder too if
it's if it's I mean there are guitarists
who have done that I don't know that
there's that many singers who've done
that sort of thing we've got the
revolving door of Yngwie Malmsteen true
yeah yeah and we can also talk about you
know that and that's where you've got
the guitarist as the the solo
centerpiece thing michael Shank noir -
we can talk about the people who've come
with him oh and and the shaker thing he
tours with all of his singers now
there's five singers and they have and
they when they're not singing lead
they're singing the harmony parts it's
actually I've seen a choice it's a must
see and you've got Robin McCauley coming
up and doing the era from there and
you've got it was in he's playing better
than ever
Michael Schenker is just one of the
greats man he's not he's not drunk and
high anymore helps god that was sad some
of the if anybody's footage of him
unable to play it was no bad and yet he
and he was kicked out a UFO for drinking
so many times and Vinnie Moore's our
guitarist but yeah that's an interesting
one because to me he was he was the whiz
kid and he was the sound of UFO well I
why don't we bring this to a close
[Music]
there's a lot we had a lot of great
questions and comments and stuff like
that I think there's a lot more to
unpack in this topic so we'll probably
knock her into some of the aspects of it
and maybe bring a little bit more you
know metaphysical rigor to it over time
but I did you know I thought it was a
good way to
satisfy the urge to talk about the ship
of theseus and some of these other
things that keep coming up over and over
again so any any last thoughts Scott
know this but this was this turned out
to be really interesting and maybe like
all kind of discussions that bring up
more questions yeah anyway and the
participation everybody's so bright here
and actually really made me think about
some of these things from another way
and I'm I'm definitely gonna be kind of
considering some of the comments and it
gets I would say yeah maybe that's what
a good discussion is is you you unpack
more and it's not as simple as you
thought it was gonna be yeah but we did
have some opinions like we you know had
be obtained a $25 ticket and you would
not yeah when you're talking about a
genre of music that spans now what five
decades yeah it's there's gonna be a lot
to talk about
alright everybody well thanks for for
joining in and thanks again Scott for
being special guest on this other at
this point where you probably just call
you a co-host you know I love it all
right I'll see you all next month
you